お釈迦様が生まれた場所はこの場所なんです
この石柱が お釈迦様がこちらで生まれたんだと
私もこちらに来て参拝をしましたと巡礼に来ましたというふうな書いてる石柱なんです
文字はこの左側にあります
お釈迦様が書いたものは
上はいくらかいたずらですけど
どうやってそこいたずら書かれたかわからない
この乱文文字で この間の発掘されたできた文字で書いてありますから
もしどなたかノート持ってきてならば
今読ませてみてます 一応あのいえ
バタゲトヤワトという言葉なんですけどね
それとあそこ様が来たっていうところですね
書いているのは で 私はこの子供の頃聞いた話で
昔ですからね これで私も５８だからね
引き算してみると まあまあ年ぐらい前のもっと前かな
で 話でかな ここら辺は砂
普通の砂で ただこれだけ一部上下そこだけあったんだって
いわゆるカニンハンたちがそういうのを発見してね
それからそのまんまでしたからね
こんなものは何もなかったんで
全部土でいっぱいでしたし
それであのみんな来て
このそちらから土を持っていくんだって
ほんのちょっとだけでも
その当時の柵はあったんですけど
もうとにかくもう何とかして土ほんのちょっとでも持っていくんだと
なぜかというと それ持ってるともうものすごい安産で
子供の時はもう何一つ問題起こらず
さっとまあ生まれるんだということで
まあすごい信仰で まあかなり派手に持っていかれたみたい
今もこちらに来て おそらく安産祈願する女性の方々がいる可能性はあります
お釈迦様の前で特別に
まあ勝手に自分の希望を祈願すればいいということで
ヒンドゥー寺みたいに
この特別にまあ神々に仕事を分けてはないんですからね
とにかくまあ お釈迦様はこちらで生まれて
こちらもサーラの木のそばでしたって書いてましたからね
その その公園は潰されて
もうかなりど派手なお寺
あっちこっち出来上がっていたんですから
だから今日私は初めて見られる
この発掘されてるお寺のいろんなお寺
仏塔の一部一部なんですね
こちらもすごいかっこ悪いお寺がありましたけどね
まあこれ壊されちゃって
今まあかっこいいかどうか
沢野さんに聞かないとわからないんですけど
一応新しい建物ができてます
こちらにあったのはマーヤデヴィの寺というマーヤデヴィ名前の
で こちらで生まれてお釈迦様は七歩お歩きになったとね
生まれてすぐ北の方ですね
北ってどこ？ 後ろ側ですね
こちらの方向で北ですね
こちらを見て歩いたんだと
その時は地面からこの美しく大きな蓮華の花が上がってきて
あのシッダールタ王子を
菩薩を受け取ったというか
足を踏んでも踏んでも土には踏めなかったんですね
地面からはその花が上がってきたんだそうです
それでまあお歩きになって終わったら
もう花がそれで消えてしまいます
他の人はその上を歩くということはないんです
そういうことで そこを七歩歩いて
アッゴーハマスミローカス
ゼットーハマスミローカス
セットーハマスミローカス
アヤマンティマージャーティナッティダーニプナッバオという四誓句というんですか
それを言いましたと アッゴーハマスミローカス
生命の中で 今私は一番上のね
あの人になりました なってるんだと
セットーハマスミローカス
生きて生きてるものの中で
まあ私は最高なものになってるんだと
ゼットーハマスミ 私こそ先輩であると
アヤマンティマージャーティナッティダーニプナッバオ
これが最後の生まれですと
まあこれから生まれ変わりはないということで
もし七歩を歩いて四方八方を見て
それからやっぱり自分がもう最後の生まれっていうことが分かって
そういうことを言いましたっていう伝説なんです
で まあウェーサーカ祭なんかお釈迦様のお誕生日なんか私やっている場合は
大体その偈を旗に書いていろんなところにお飾りをしたりします
それはあの まあ経典ではないんですけどね
仏典で出てくる言葉ですね
えーと 調子入れて言うとどうなるんでしょうかね
あれは 昔は日本では CD あったんです
私がそれ唱えた分は 彫刻家の先生は
西村晃三先生のところで
一つそういうエピソードいろいろ入れて CD 作ったんで
そこでこれ必要やと言ったところで
ではやってみます アッゴ ハマス ミロ カッセ
ジェトウ ハマス ミロ カッセ セットウ ハマス ミロ カッセ アエマンティ マジャティ ナッティダニ プナバウというくらいです
阿闍梨の時だから短いんです
では説法が始まりますので
まず南無陀羅尼 南無陀羅尼 陀羅尼 陀羅尼 サマンサット ニャセ ナモ グダセ
説法のまとめを説明いたします
ドゥエメ
ビッケウェ アンタ パッバジテー ナナ セウィタンバ ヨーチャランカーメ スカーマ スカルリカーヌヨーゴ
ヘーノー ガッモー コートゥンダンニコ アナリーヨー アナッタサンニトー ヨーチャランアッタ キレ
マターヌヨーゴ ドゥミポーアナリーヨー アナッタサンニトー エテーテー ビッケウェー ヨーゴ アンテー アンタガ
ッマ マッジマー パティパダー タターガテーナ アビサンブッダ チャックカルニニャーナカルニー ウパサマーイ アヴィンニャーエ
サンボーダーヤ ニッバーナーヤ サンワッタエーティ
それは経典の一番初めのお釈迦様の言葉なんです
ドゥエーメ ビッケウェという言葉で始めたんです
で 言われは言うと 昨日の大塔のところで悟り開いて
四十五日間 その間でいろんな
この周りでね お釈迦様が一周間
二週間 三週間 五か所いたんですね
その七週間目の場所っていうのは
テーラワーダ仏教では大変大変大事にするんです
我々はこの七カ所のいちげえにまで
スリランカでって礼拝するんです
パタマンボディパッランカンドゥティアンチャニンニサンという芸なんですけど
だから私たちにとってはこのちゃんと七か条も行かないと気が済まないんです
大乗仏教では七週間という考え方はないんです
3週間か 4週間ですね
どうですか？大乗仏教は
一番短いのは 1週間  1週間に
一番短い  一応経典では 4週間
大乗経典でも 4週間ぐらいは記録しているみたいですよ
7週間はやってないんですが
しかしこちらに来てみたらちゃんと 7か所歩くことはあります
それでこの礼拝する芸っていうのは大体誰かが作ったものでね
今言ってる芸でもね パタマンボディパッランカンっていうのはね
どなたかが遠い昔に作ったもので
一応読み上げます あのパタマンボディパッランカン
パテ
マンボディパッランカンドゥティアンチェアニンニサンタティアンチャンカマナムセッタンチャトゥッタムラテナアグラムパンチェマンアジャパランチェウッチリンデンチャッテマンサッテマンラジャラテナム
ワンディタムニッシーリタム
ワンデータムニッシーリタム
ということです 通ってない
スリランカでそんな問題
お母さんたちに聞かないと
[笑い]そうやってこの七か条なんです
で 一つ一つ思い浮かんで礼をする
それからお釈迦様がタパスバングラという二人から丸いみたんですね
米をあげたもの そういうものはいただいて
蜂蜜と一緒にそれを召し上がって
まあ説法しないことにしたんですね
それで梵天が下りてきて
だから梵天の名前まで
この一応ヒンドゥー教の一番上のトップクラスの人々が信仰していた人類を創造したという神様なんです
全ての人類をね ヒンドゥー教はクラスごとに神様が現れるんです
そこでこのバラモンカーストのでも
知識人系の人々はこのサハンプティというマハブラフマというブラフマを神様として拝んでいます
インドどこへ行ったってもマハブラフマの陣
陣 登場です この場合は
神様の層ね ないんです
ヴィシュヌやらいろんなもうシヴァやらね
そういうこのいろんな民族信仰の神々なんですね
拝んでいるのは アディ人のメンのチャネルはもうおのあるとはマハブラフマですけど
誰もまあ信仰してない
だからまあお釈迦様は一番エリートの中
上のエリートでしたから
このバラモン人の中でも知っているのはもうエリート中エリートなんですね
だからそのブラフマなんですね
サハンプティっていうのは
で バラモン人がこの世界と人間は創造した神様だと信仰しているんです
自分は仏教から見れば
実際にそういう神はいるんだと
でも創造したわけじゃないんだという立場を取っています
とにかく何回何回お釈迦様に会って話したりして
仲良くはしていました
そのバラモン 梵天がまあ説法してくださいと頼まれて
で 上で説法に出かけるんですね
その時はアララカラーナ仙人とウッダカラーナブッタというね
仙人二人がお釈迦様にも教えていただいたんだから
あの先生二人ならもうぴったしわかるだろうと
インドではってたった一人ですね
言ってもこれ亡くなっていたんですね
もう梵天でもこのコンタクトできない
虫みたいにいるんだから
もう何もコンタクトできない
体も何もない だから大変損しましたと
私の先生二人は それから考えたら
やっぱり自分の友人たち 5人ですね
彼らがお釈迦様と別れて
あの辺でお釈迦様はご飯召し上がっていたんだから
このボートガヤの方で
まあ最後にそちらあったので
お粥をいただいて そこでご飯もらってたんだから
まあ喧嘩して別れてこちらに来ていたんです
サーラナガムね こちらに来て
自分勝手でせっかく期待していたシッダルタ王子もだらしないと
もうどうしようもなくてね
結構悲しかったでしょうと思いますけどね
ものすごい期待して出家したんだからね
お世話するっとお世話していましたし
側にいたし そこでそこからお釈迦様ここまで歩いてきたんです
歩いてきている途中でまあ二人に会ったんですね
記録としていくと 一人がバラモン人が何か質問しまして
すごい難しい質問で お釈迦様は淡々と真理だけ答えたんです
さっぱりわからなかったんです
そのバラモン人には それでベルを出して帰っちゃったんです
まあわからないということも
それからそんなに頭が良くないアジール
ジャイナ系とちょっと親戚の宗教の人がお釈迦様を見たんですね
見たらもうびっくりして
もうものすごくお出かけ
大体誰でもお釈迦様見たらびっくりする
一つは若さ もう家も家だから
もうこんな道路を歩く人ではないでしょうし
だからすごい人相もある
ものすごい人格者が まだ若くて
どこかに歩いていると
みんな誰でしょうかってびっくりするんです
それでこのウパカという人なんですけど
彼がお釈迦様を見たら
なんといい人でしょうか
歩き方を見たら もう自分の心はずっと静かに
もうお出かけになっていくんです
自分が何かすごく悩んでいたんです
何かすごく問題があって
それでお釈迦様に会って
あなたはもうどなたでしょうか
どんな教えでしょうかと聞くんじゃなくて
あなたの先生は誰ですかと聞いているんです
言ったらお釈迦様はもうすごい大胆で
私の先生いませんよと
ナメアーチャリワッチーナメパティプティパティポッカロ
私に先生はいません 私に比べる比較する人も存在しませんよと
サデワカスミローカスミン
カミガミボンテン もう全ての生命の中で
私は一人で真理を発見してブッダになったような
だから私に比べる人もいませんよ
先生のところかと 言うと
人間としてはそんな大胆な言葉っていうのは
もう冗談ででも言うもんじゃないんですよ
私は神様よりも偉いぞっていうことだからね
だから当たり前のことで
ウパカはすごくびっくりしちゃったんですね
それで で あなた言うこと本当であるならば
あなたはアナンタジナではないかと
アナンタジナっていうのは勝利者ですね
アナンタっていうのはもう切れない無限ということでね
無限の勝利者ではないかと
あまり日本訳にしたら意味がないんですね
切りがなく いわゆる完全たる勝利者というかね
という風に言ってもいいんじゃないかと
言ったら お釈迦様 なんのことなくマーディサーウィージナーホンディ
まあ勝利者と言えば 私のようなものに言う言葉だよと
なぜならば 全ての罪を私は勝ちましたと
罪に勝ちましたと もう何もないんだと
心には今はね ということで
でもウパカは別にわかってないんです
ということはね 本人が自分の悩みがあったのに
私にも何とか助けてちょうだいと言ったら
お釈迦様教えるはずでしたけど
聞かなかったんですね
ただ名刺だけ交換したような感じで
それで もうあまりにも大胆な名刺ですから
お釈迦様ももうちょっと歯が立たないんですね
それで彼がわかりましたということで帰りました
しかし彼が あの来て出家したんです
彼がどうかいっても まあだらしない男で
あのどこかで女の人と恋に落ちちゃって
そこ結婚しちゃったんですね
修行をやめて それで あんたも修行をやめたんだから
もう結婚したんだからね
前みたいにたかり食わすわけにはいきませんと
仕事をしなさいと 仕事仕事できん
ろくに仕事できない 怠け者で
まあ結婚した相手にもさんざんバカにされる
そこである日 なんか畑仕事をして家に帰ると
赤ちゃんが泣いていて
お母さんがなんかその俗歌に歌を作って
旦那が来るのを見たんですね
あの怠け者の息子をもう泣かないでおれにねという風な歌を歌ったみたいですね
だらしない男 だらしない父親の息子じゃ静かにおれんねとかね
あのインド語 サンスクリット語
パーリ語 どれぐらい自分の国の言葉でも結構俗歌に歌を作れるんですよ
結構節を合わせて だからそれは別に仕事ではない
まあこうやって考える必要はないんです
それ聞いてものすごくプライド傷ついちゃって
そのまま家に帰らなかったんです
お前にバカにされたって
私には立派な人 友達がいるんだよ
お前らみたいな人と全く違うんだよと
知り合いがいるんだよと
何も見えでもないと思ってるんでしょうかということで
もう怒鳴ってそのまま帰ってお釈迦様のところに行って出家はしたんです
一応伝承それではなんでウパカが何も話に行かなかったということ
やっぱり決まりとしては人の比丘たちには最初の説法をするという決まりで
この人の方々も結局過去生でもう長い間修行を積んで修行を積んで
その祈願して誓願して生きているんです
ブッダの最初の説法は我々に聞か聞けますようにということで
だから そういう輪廻の中で徳を積んで徳を積んで誓願したものは
必ずその通りになるんです
それは変えることはできない
例えば アナンダ尊者がお釈迦様が自分にはお世話役が必要やと言ったところで
サーリプッタ尊者からみんなじゃあ私がやってあげますとかね
偉いお坊さんたちがみんな出たんです
お釈迦様は断るんです
いいといいといいと アナンダ尊者だけ黙っている
それでお坊さんたちはみんなアナンダ尊者に我々みんな勝手出て
このお釈迦様のお世話したいとですけど
お釈迦様は断る あんただけなんでついつい黙ってるんですかって
私はそんなことは頼みませんよと
もし私がこの住職 住職でした
何でしたっけ？住職として私に資格あるならば
お釈迦様が言ってくれるでしょうね
だから私なんかは聞きません
そんなこと聞かない それでお釈迦様はみんなもう断られたんだから
やっぱりアナンダ尊者がアナンダアナンダが私のお世話するでしょうと
というお釈迦様を頼むんですね
頼んだところ アナンダ尊者がすぐ立って
でも条件付きですと やりますけど
いくつか条件がありますよと
でお釈迦様とは条件交わすことはできません
もうこれは大変な危険なことで
その言葉は言ってもいけないんです
ブッダの前で でもアナンダ尊者がそれを言ったんです
言ったら まあどういうものかと聞いたら
いくつかの条件があって
それを言ったんです お釈迦様も認めたんです
それはお世話する人が必ず守らなくちゃいけないものなんです
お釈迦様のお布施は自分はもらえませんと
だからお釈迦様もこれもらってくださいと言ってはいけません
言うと困りますからね
断りませんからと たとえお釈迦様がご飯召し上がって
どなたからごちそうをもらっていただいて
もうお世話する人に半分あげるのは普通でしょ
では あげてはいけないと
それでアナンダ尊者 今あんたは托鉢に出かけなかったんで
出かけなくてもいいでしょう
今ご飯がありますからということは
お釈迦様言ってはいけないんです
もう約束だから そういうふうな条件なんです
8個 それはどういうことかというと
アナンダ尊者いいですね
お釈迦様のご飯もらっているんだからというふうな一言葉聞きたくないんです
苦労しなくてもいいですね
アナンダ尊者はと その一言葉聞きたくない
それからまたあります
その説明したって意味がないんですけど
どなたがお釈迦様に会いたくなっても
まずアナンダ尊者から許可をもらわなくちゃいけないんです
勝手に会ってはいけないと
ということで 一応お釈迦様の管理なんですね
身の回りの世話だからね
それを全部認めて そういうことになりましたし
アーナンダ尊者の話すると場じゃないんですね
アーナンダ尊者もやっぱり過去生からそうやって功徳を積んでパーリピタという修行を積んで
この侍者になることを誓願していたんです
だからもう過去生からの心の中でのそれで慣れてるんですね
だからその位はいただくんです
だから五人比丘たちはやっぱりその位をね
その名誉をね 最初の説法を聞くということは
その五人にはあることで
で それでお釈迦様が最初の説法をしたんです
それも楽ではなかったんです
最初は断られたんです
私たちは朝登った 大変拙拙なことで仏塔の上まで登ってね
まあまあ それは置いといて
仏塔っていうのは蓮如さんが登るものじゃないんですけど
作る人だけなんですけどね
あの 私たちも仏塔 天狗乗ったりする時だけしか登りません
その時は大変謝って登りますけどね
そちらでいたんですね
五人が それで遠くから見たんですね
来るのは 他の人々知りません
誰 誰ですかと で もしかするとお釈迦様
初めてここまで下りてきた可能性もあるしね
北の方からね で この五人は知ってます
すぐ遠くを見つけて あ
シッダールタ王子やと
探してくるんではないかな
どうせ探してくるんだからね
言うても子供の頃から一緒にいたんだから
夜食ご飯も食べてね もう修行もやめちゃって
もう堕落してまた尼御殿に
今度はお世話しないぞと
挨拶もしてはいけないんだと
あんた方とみんなで団結してたんです
挨拶してはいけない 迎えに行ってはいけない
でもやっぱりカーストはね
バラモンカーストよりはすごく上だから
カースト制度を守らなくちゃいけないんですね
人間の社会のシステム
仕切りだから だから困ったですからね
一応座るところだけ用意しましょう
どうせ殺生食の食族の人だからね
座るところだけ置いておきましょう
それだったら我々人間としても行儀が悪いことになりますからと
そういうことで お座りになる場所だけ用意しておいたんですね
で まあ無視して待ってるんですけど
まあちょうどそこら辺に違ってくると
何のことなく一人がもうちゃんと立ち上がったんですね
立ち上がってお釈迦様の鉢ですけどね
鉢をもうはいどうぞとお荷物を受け取るような感じでね
何のことなく受け取ったんですね
その人 それを受け取っちゃう
次の人もどうしようもない
行って足を洗って入るんだから
足を洗う場所を用意したり
もう結局はもう団結は何も私だけの団結力みたいにもう全然もう
人が来たらね 何だか分からなくなっちゃったような状態になりましたし
それでもこの比丘たちが
お釈迦様 あれ この友達仲間を呼ぶ言葉でアーウソという言葉でお釈迦様を呼んだんですね
言ったらその言葉使ってはいけない
まあいわゆる仲間じゃないんだと私は
今もう修行終了してるんだと
ブッダになってるんだと
それもう笑笑なんですよ
あれほど苦行をして悟らなかったあなたは
よくも美味しいご飯食べてね
もう筋肉もついて 何言うんでしょうかということで
いえ もうそんなことはありませんと
もう真理は分かりました
苦しみはなくなりましたと
悟りましたと言ったらまた断られたんですね
だから３回も断ったんです
認めません そんなこと
そのエピソードは この仏教っていうのは
ただ単にもう聞くだけの世界じゃないんです
やっぱりもうちゃんともうお互いにもう気に入らないことは言う
反論する その形をずっと守ってるんです
でお釈迦様も３回も断られたら
お釈迦様にもやることもどうしようもないんですね
それでお釈迦様もまあ私が使っている日本語で言えば腹が立ったでしょう
もうもうもうもうキレちゃったんです
まあ怒ることは絶対ありませんですけどね
お釈迦様の聖地でこんな言葉言っちゃうと間違いありませんね
お釈迦様歩きになった聖地でしょうにね
私はこんなことこの前言ったことあるのかと
あんた方に １回だけ で
ドーンと もうそのもう最後の切り札出したんですね
それ出しちゃうと みんなもうやっぱりと
あれほど苦行をしていたのに
ひとかけらもお釈迦様が瞑想が進んでいるんだぞとか何も言わなかったんです
だからまあなんとかあるんじゃないかなと
また釈迦族っていうのは
まあ殺されても嘘つかないという決まりがありますからね
まあそういうことでまあ認めることになりました
それでお釈迦様は私はもう真理を知っていて
君たちに最初に悟る方法を教えますということで
それでそれでいて こちらでダメクストゥーパ
これはダルマチャッカストゥーパなんですね
元の名前はダルマチャッカストゥーパ
今はダメカストゥーパになってます
これなまりでしょうね
ダルマチャッカっていうのはちょっと発音しにくいし
これで現地の人々の間でどんどんなまってなまって
習俗する時はまたダメカかということになっているんです
でもこういう場所なんかは全部考古学的に全部もう確認されているしっかりしたところなんです
そちらでお釈迦様がこの５人に夜
この説法をなさったんです
これはもう最初の説法といっても
一晩通し喋るぐらいの話ではないんです
これはおそらくこの項目だけなんです
仏教の 現代風に言えば
説法のメモぐらいのことで
だから内容はものすごい大変な内容なんです
そこで最初にお釈迦様が語ったのは
この修行の道 修行 修行と言うんだけど
これまだ発見してない
はっきりと みんな修行と思っちゃうと苦行だと思うんですね
で このルートで見ることはできないんだけど
ヒンドゥールートでも組み立てて来てみてください
ヒンドゥのまとも 真面目な人々はどれほど苦しいことをやっているのかと
このジャイナ教は裸でいるだけじゃない
ヒンドゥー教もいるんですよ
すごい裸でいて もうあれこれと信じられない
もう体痛めるということをやってます
で そこでも体痛めることが修行だと思っている世界が
もう一つは そんな死んでからどうでもいいよ
もう遊んで食って踊って
もうもう楽しくいれば
それこそ人生の目的だという次の道
これもヒンドゥー教にも堂々とあります
あの楽しく遊んで歌って踊ってふざけていれば
それこそ人生は全うするものやと
インドの映画なんか見ても
まあそのヒンドゥー教のその世界なんです
あんなふざけた映画でも
やっぱり宗教は入ってますよ
ずっと中に そういう道なんですね
彼らがやっているのは
あの音楽 インド音楽を聴きたければ
まあどこかのヒンドゥー教のこのこういうお寺みたいなところに行ってみればね
結構生演奏で またほとんど即興で歌ったり
歌ったり踊ったりします
また この CD の音楽よりは気分がいいんです
結構いいんですよ その歌は
それは一つの宗教のやり方なんです
ヒンドゥー教 だからお釈迦様はこの道２つはダメだと
お釈迦様がもっと統一した
choice した もっと聖なる
もっと品格のある中道を発見しました
それがチャックカラに目が覚めてくれる
ニャーナカラに智慧が現れてくれ
ウパサマーヤ 心は落ち着いてくれ
アビニャーヤ 超越した智慧を発見される
まあ現れてくる ニッバーナは涅槃を体験できる
いう中道を私は発見しましたと
だから中道というのは曖昧という意味ではありません
このすごいインテリな道がありますよという意味なんです
修行を通してインテリな道でありますよと
それが八正道ですね 有名な正見
正思惟とかね だから正見といったところで
ものすごいインテリだけど
正見 物事はものすごいしっかり正しく観察しなくちゃいけない
考えるならば 下らんことではなくて
しっかりと物事を考えなくちゃいけない
喋るならば きちんとした正しいことしか喋れなくちゃいけない
やることはしっかり行動を考えてしっかりした行動をやらなくちゃいけない
生活はあんなものを買うたり
人からものを買うたりとかね
ものを盗んだりとかね
この商売に対してすごい戒律の中でいろんなことを言ってるんですよ
だからインドの社会 今見ても経典の意味がわかるんですよ
トゥラー買うた カンサ買うた
マーナ買うた ニカティカ
すごい単語ありますよ
量ると何かごまかす あの秤いくつかありますから
米とかこうやって量ってあげるでしょ
米量ってあげるとも 指 2本ぐらい中に入れて量って
はい 4つ大丈夫だよ これでも平気でやるんですそんなことは
それでもう 100 ルピーって言えば 10 ルピーでしょう
値段は それで儲かってますよ
だからまあこれがもう遺伝的にも人を騙すのはもう遺伝的にもあることで
もうこの国の人々 で もうまあインドはもう世界一つの小さなサンプルみたいなものだから
こんなこと言ったってインド人みんなそうってわけじゃないんです
世界は全部 1箇所にまとめるとインドなんです
何でもありき 人間もそうですよ
白人よりすっごい美しい皮膚の色の人々もいる
黒人にほぼ近い黒い色の人々もいるし
だから色から見ても全部もう
あの 何て言いますか あの
全部あります 性格からもものすごい立派な人から
もう信じられないほどだらしない人までもいる
ないのは犯罪者はないですね
大胆な 大胆な犯罪者はない
そういうくらいのことです
だから仏教でもこういうだらしない生き方
値段だったら正しい値段
品物っていうのは作る時はお金かかるわ
いくらか利益は必要でしょうし
運ぶ時は値段かかる そこは入れて値段言えばいいんです
だから仏教の世界ではほとんど安値でも決めるんですよ
皆様 スリランカに旅行する時は私は行ったと思いますけど
あまりねじれないと思います
向こうでは 値段言ったらその値段です
で 時々高いと感じるかもしれません
だけど それなりの訳があって
そちらにその値段設定していて
これはですけど 一応円に円にしようかっていうことはないんです
それは向こうは全然しません
まあ最近いくらか潰れてますけど
まあそれでもそれほどはないんですよ
で ちょっと値段下げている場合は
頼まなくても下げてくれる
下げることできる場合はね
大体僕は買い物をするときは
まあこれはまあです じゃあお坊さんだから
じゃあで まあこれはじゃあこれはやっぱりまあしかできませんとかね
それで本人が自分勝手に値段下げられるならばね
下げて だからすごいもう早くまあ商売できます
まあそういうことで このまあそういう生き方
サンマアーチーバ 汚い生き方やめなさいと
そうやってお釈迦様八正道教えた
だから八正道はすごい品格のある教えなんです
そこを歩むと必ず悟られるんだよと
そこで最後に正念 皆様瞑想してるでしょ
ヴィパッサナー瞑想の
ヴィパッサナー瞑想というのは正念という部分なんです
そこで清浄という心を統一する
心を統一すると また正見が現れてくる
そうするとさらに正業やら進んでいって
また正念が進むんです
そうするとまた清浄が現れてきて
また正見が出てくるんです
そういうサイクルで だから法輪なんです
私たちにはまあ正見で言ったって
もうそんなこと考えられないでしょうに
でも いくらか本当のことを聞いただけでも正見なんですよ
でもそれだけでは悟りません
それから残りの正思惟
正語 まあ正語 また正命
そうやって頑張っていくんですよ
正精進 正念と清浄と 自分なりに頑張る
自分なりに頑張ると清浄が現れてきて
それなりの  なんとか清浄が現れてくると
前よりは何とか正見が現れてくるんです
また続けて頑張ってみると
また清浄に行くでしょ
落ち着くでしょ またなんとかより正見が現れてくるんです
そうやって清浄で正見が生まれていくというサイクルがあるんです
そのサイクルで行って悟れるんですよ
悟りにも正見というんです
だからそれは結構頭がよく働かない人にはこれわからない
なんで正見の説明は涅槃の説明とおぼろ同じで
また別なことを後で言うんでしょうか？と
順番間違ってるんではないかとかね
そうじゃないんです これは明確にすごい気に込んだこと考えたものなんです
それで道を教えてから
お釈迦様はつの真理を紹介したんです
このつしか真理がないんだよと
1番目は苦しみに対する真理
これ みんな世界を無視するんですよ
生きることが大変であって
簡単じゃない 何をしたっても大変で簡単じゃないんですよ
でも人間っていうのはなんか贅沢できないか
贅沢できないかと もう遠く見ているんですよ
まあどちらでも人生は全体的に大変なものであって
苦しいことをやって いくら我々はいいものを探していても
結局は年取ってくたびれて死ぬでしょうに
苦しいでしょうに 誰かに儲かりたいと頑張って頑張って大金大金は手に入るともう年取ってるんですよ
もうもういいです あってもなくても
だから結局悔しくなるんですよ
そういうことだから 人間
まず人生を直視するべきですよと
それがなんでそんなに強調するかというと
世界のすべての宗教が我々にはアトマンがあるんではないかと
パラマアトマンというものがあるんではないかと
素晴らしい魂があるんではないかと
これは永遠不滅で 神様のなんとかものやとかね
そうやってこの言う話なんですよ
キリスト教でもイスラム教でもヒンズー教でももうジャイナ教でも宗教と言えばもう魂の話
でも実際の人生というのはものすごく惨めで大変で
ろくなことはない だからろくなことはないということは
この連中は認めない だから仏教はもうバカじゃないかと
魂やら霊魂やら何言ってるんですかと
そんなに不死なる魂あるならば
もう僕の言葉で言えば
電車でも来る時は首でも入れてみればどうですかね
線路に 魂は死なんだから
また首つなげればぴったしと
そんなことないでしょうに
この階段から落ちたって死んじゃいますからね
だからこのくだらんことを言わないで事実見なさいよ
階段から降りたってもあんた死ぬんだよ
あるいはもう寝たきりになってひどい病気になるんだよ
そういうことは西洋人が仏教は何主義？このペシミズムだと
悲観主義が 違うんです
で テーラワーダの人々を見てください
悲観主義者がいるんでしょうか？もう真面目に瞑想するながらも
誰かちょっとけなしたり
ずったり なんとかふざけたりして
もう結構明るくいるんですよ
だから 例えばこういう聖地にいたっても
私にしたっても 別に怯えるほどっていうのはないんですよ
なんかお釈迦様のそばだから
まあちょっとふざけてやるかなという気分になるぐらいのもう気分がいいだけなんです
だから我々は一生先わからないんだから
階段であのあのうたらデブはもうこけそうになっちゃったしね
あれはあのあのあのシャミたちに応じた徳ですね
すぐもう結果が良いことをすると
もうすぐ良い結果があるということだと思いますけどね
まあわからない だからこのちょっと足が滑っても体が壊れるということで
私たちは人生ということは気をつけるんです
何から何まで だから仏教徒の場合はもう自然災害はもうゼロに違いない
伝染病なんかではもうみんな信者でほとんどもう 1%ぐらい
常に気をつける 何だかんでも
大金持ちにはなりませんだけど
まあどん底貧乏には全然なりません
仏教の仲間だったら まあそう必死はさせませんよ
もうなんとか協力する
だからこの仕事をクビになった
だから自殺するんだっていうことは
自分たちの国では起こりません
別に気にしない 仕事がクビになったと
これからどうしようかとあまり気にしない
なさらば まあまあみんな心配するんだからね
それはない だからこの我々悲観主義者じゃないんですよ
現実主義者なんです 事実見るだけ
ありのままに 死にかけてる人に
おばあちゃん なんとか頑張って長生きしなさいと絶対言わない
おばあちゃんもよく頑張ったねと言うんです
もう過去形で はっきり事実を言うんですよ
だから死にかけてる人を結構明るいんです
何か言うんですよ その時
でもまあこちら何か言ったらもう喋るんだったら言い返しするんです
だからこのそうやってこの現実主義
この 1番目の真理っていうの
だから世の中は今も現実主義でなければいけません
妄想しちゃうと 俺が偉いと思っちゃうと
イラクでは爆弾落としてひどい目に遭っているでしょうに
アメリカの若者はね そういうことになって世界の戦争に引っ張られるだけで
現実主義で物事を見ると
みんなお互いに仲良く生きてるんですよ
どうせ短い人生だから
こんな人を殺す暇がないんですよ
人殺しに行くでしょ 鉄砲を持って
その連中にも人生あるでしょうに
アメリカの若者たちにもね
まあ麻薬でも打って もういろいろ遊んだりして
音楽ロック音楽で聴いたりして
またなんとか仕事をして結婚してと
普通人生っていうのはあるでしょうに
だからもう道 人生は短いと思った人が人生を大事にする
戦争なんかに行かない
そんな暇がないんです
結婚して子供育て 子供を大きくさせたりとかね
忙しいんですよ だからもうその人生をお釈迦様が語っていて
これ未だに通じる教えなんです
2番目はなんでこんなに苦しむのかというと
インドのこの世界見るとわかります
強烈な欲なんです この魂あるという考え方の強烈な渇愛なんですよ
だからもう例えばインドのこの周りの人々は
自分が苦しんでいるということ全然振り返って見ないでしょ
ただ手を出してこうするだけで
それで 1ルピーぐらいもらったら
それでもらった相当喜んで帰っちゃうだけで
で 腹が立ちますよ あんなもので喜ぶべきかと
もっと真剣に人生っていうのを考えたらどうですか？考えないでしょう
それが渇愛というんですよ
スリランカからでもいろいろ活動を始めたんで
こちらでこういう子供たちに何とか学校でも何とかして
もうもうやりましょう
で かなりスリランカ人というのは結構もうあれだから
もう結構結束前もっていくんだから
もうお金なければ日本からでも中国からでも引っ張って持ってきますよ
でもこちらでうまくいかないんですよ
ネパールで学校なんか始めて
子供たち学校に行かせてない
ネパールの人夫さんたちがもうあちこちをたどって学校を始めたんですよ
いきなり 政府は禁止しちゃった
それでダメ それでもう腹が立って攻撃してやろうと思ったっても
こちらで攻撃して学校を作る権利を取ったっても作れませんから
政府は協力しないとね
あんまり何もしてなかったんです
だからこの人生は厳密に見るともっと豊かになるんです
だから電車で私はインドの苦しみをなくすために何か方法ないかなと考えていて
案は 1つは出ましたけど
それはもうとっくに発表しましたから
今は言いません 案 2番目はそれなんです
もう人生を見てほしい
一人一人自分の人生はね
いわゆる渇愛 欲が良くないんだと
タンハは良くないんだと
それで私はこの子供たちにこのお金をあげる時でも誰かに言ったんですよ
みんなにはあげない そこでまあもらうわけでもない
こんな連中いる 時々こう言って諦める子供たちいるんですよ
まあもうまあこんな連中いるんだから
まあもらうわけじゃないって自分であんなこと私すっかり見るんです
あの瞬間に欲がないんですよ
私はその子を狙ってちょっとあげるんです
で それもなんとなく もう一回だけバスで
一人の子がもう全然バスの方を見ないでね
別に自分が他のとこ見ていてよ
だからじゃあこの子にあげるぞと思って
わしはもうちょっと指をさしてみたら子供わかったんですね
で まあ来ると まあお金出しても何人か前いたんですよ
でもその連中わかったんで
私はあの子供にあげたがっているんだと
だからちゃんと前出して
お前お前だよと だからやっぱり欲がない瞬間というのは
それでうまくいくんです
まあそういうことで この 2番目
なんでこんなに苦しみののかというと
この渇愛 金持ちがもっと欲しい欲しいと
ない連中も人生は客観的に見ない
客観的に見ると こんな土地なんか奪っちゃってね
まあ自分たちも豊かになりますよ
別にみんなの土地でしょうに
一人のものじゃないでしょうに
だからまあ 2番目の真理はそういうことで
心は渇愛あると苦しむ
3番目はもう渇愛なくなっちゃうとすごく平和になるんだと
4番目はこの道 今教えた八正道を歩んでくださいという説法なんです
それでこの論理的に終了します
それで話も終了します
この 1番目の真理は苦しみに対する真理
それは知り尽くす だからサンセットなんです
生老病死は苦しみである
この真理は知り尽くすべき
3番目 私はこれを知り尽くしました
と  1番目の真理には三説
3つの条件が 条件じゃない段階があります
2番目の真理 渇愛は苦しみの元である
それはなくすべきである
私はそれをなくしましたとはっきりする
それで 3番目の真理は渇愛なくなった状態
涅槃は 3番目の真理である
それは体験するべきである
私はそれを体験しました
それで 4番目の真理 八正道
これが八正道である  1番目
2番目 この八正道を実践するべきものである
いわゆる行わなくちゃ意味がない
それで私は実践しましたと
そうすると四つの真理が十二項目になるんです
それはティパリワッタンドワダサーカランと言うんです
こちらにあります  二十八ページの下から二番目の段落から
二番目の下から二番目の段落
ヤーワキーワンチェメーディッキャウェイイメーシュチャトゥスワリヤサッチーエーシュエワンティパリワッタンダーダサーカランというところ
ティパリワッタースリーサイクルス十二形あるということでね
それが私ははっきりとあるがままに理解していなかった時はブッダだと言っていなかったと
この世の中で神々梵天
すべての生命の中で 私こそたった一人ブッダだよと言っていなかったと
そんなこと しかし 私は今
この三点十二なんか日本語あります？それには
三点と小節かな まあ一応三点十二方法ということで
十二種類でこの八正道をわかったからこそ
最後の段落 ヤタヤブータニャーナダサスィシダガホーシ
アタ
ーハンビッカウェーサデーワケーローケーサマーラケーサブラフマケーサッサマナーブラフマニャーパジャーヤサデーワマヌッサーヤアヌッタランサッマーサンボーディンアビサンブッドーパッチャンニャーシン
というところで終了するんですね
そこで意味は一言一言言うんです
この十二サイクルのこれをわかったんだからアターハンビッカウェーサデーワケーローケー
この世の中で神々も含めて
この世の中でサマーラケーマーラ悪魔も入ってますと
サブラフマケーブラフマも入ってますよと
そういうみんな入ってるこの世界で
人間でいえばシャモンバラモン
みんな入ってるんだ この世界でサデーワマヌッサーヤアヌッタランサッマーサンボーディン
この上ない悟りをアビサンブッドー悟っているんだと
パッチャンニャーシン認めます
表現します だから人間にはもう決して言えない言葉なんです
冗談ででもこんな大胆な言葉を言えません
でもお釈迦様はちゃんと論理に則って
この四つわかればブッダだよ
でも四つだけじゃ足りません
それは三点で三回のセットで十二のやり方でやらなくちゃいけない
いわゆる体験しなくちゃいけないということで
それであの経典は初転法輪経はその経で終了するんですよ
その説法終わったところでこの地面が揺れたんです
ここら辺の線が その それで
あの あの人間に 神々にも考えられないものすごい光で
すごいこの八万何千世界です
こちら書いてますけどね
光ったんです すごい光が現れた
で この今の現代科学者が言ってる場所がありますね
あのブラックホールという言葉がありますね
宇宙の中でこの絶対光が入らないところという仏典でも絶対光が入らないところも宇宙の中にありますよ
もう何のことなく言ってます
それはローハンというか部分ですね
あのお釈迦様が最初に説法した時
放った光がそちらまで届くんです
それ普通の光じゃないんです
普通の光だったらブラックホールには入りません
そこまでもうこの宇宙全部広げていったんだと
それで阿修羅王様のあの柱で
なんでライオンですかと
これ あの お釈迦様のこの態度表現しているんです
これ以上はもう誰にも言えませんと
だから動物の中でライオンがすごい偉いと人間が思ってますけどもね
ライオンはそう思ってないんです
で 別に人間がそう思ってるんですね
ライオンはすごくもう動物の中で王様だと
だから獅子宮ということにしているんです
そこは四方八方にもう話したと
だからあの上で美しい法輪が載せてあったんですよ
もう壊れてますけどね
それは阿修羅王様がお釈迦様のこの態度を体で感じて
そこはああいうことをイメージをイメージして石柱を作っておいたんですね
そういうことで お釈迦様は世界に真理を初めて発表した場所で
たった人でしたけど それは大胆な歴史的な出来事で
だから今発掘されているんだからね
いかに大胆であったかとお分かりになるでしょう
また ここら辺もいろいろもう発掘することはできないし
もうここら辺 全部もうブッダの世界でしたと思いますよ
そこでヨアン・チョアン
玄奘さんが来た時も もう信じられないほどもうたくさんこちらにもお寺がいっぱいあって
だからまあ当時で宗派仏教もありましたけど
一緒にいたんですね みんな今もこちらでいろんなお坊さんたち一緒にいるでしょ
ラーマさんもみんな一緒に
昔もそんな感じで もう中国のお坊さんたちも来るし
まあそうやって昔からもそんな形なんですね
あの宗派仏教になった時でも
一箇所に来て修行するって
まあ感動的な話はなかなかできないので
えーと 私は朝お経をあげた時は全部フルバージョンでお経をあげましたけど
長いんです その時は このお経をお釈迦様が今言った文章で初転法輪は終わったんです
たった分で終わるぐらいのセットなんです
これ一応メモだけなんですね
初転法輪 お釈迦様おっしゃった教えの
それ終わったらこの地面にいた神々は
何て言いますか このお釈迦様がブッダが今日今法輪を回せましたと
それで生命に真理を語られましたよと言って
すごい大きい声でそれをもう神々が言ったんです
それで上の国王のある四天王のレベルの神々が
その声を聞いて また同じ声を出して
もっと上の神々に報告するんです
それで梵天までアカニッタという梵天の一番頂点まで
すぐ即座にみんなに報告が伝わったんです
その報告がみんなに伝わったということは
すぐ丁寧に唱えるんです
一向に一向に それですごく長くなるんです
そこでその瞬間で 全宇宙のすべての生命がもう一応真理がもう世の中に現れましたということを知りましたということで
経典は終わります では
何か知りたいことがございますか？で
それを聞いて コンラジ長老が人の一番目の年上の人が予言を語りました
それからお釈迦様はすーっと一人一人一人に瞑想指導はしました
で それでどこかにそれで行って
みんなまとめて無我に徹してもう一度説法したんです
一番引っかかっているのは
この魂という私という概念なんですね
それを潰されたところで
人もいっぺんに阿羅漢になったんです
それからガヤ仙人やら伝道始めたんです
このガヤ仙人のところに行かれますかね
なんとかさ 聞いたこと
なんかそんな話って耳に入ったこと
なんとか仙人たちになんとかなんとかって言わなかったっけ
三兄弟  そうそうそうそう
そういうことで これこそ世界で現れた世界宗教で
民主差別はない 時代遅れにはならない
人間の問題にはすばりと答えがある
ブッダの教えがある場合は
政治も安定する 国も安定する
貧困もなくなる 搾取も消える
みんな元気にもなる 誰か誰かをいじめるということはもうなくなる
大変なもう信じられない教えなんです
で 全くもだらしないもう野蛮人の方々にももう跡形もなく潰されたんですけど
だからお釈迦様はそれを知っていたみたいしね
この国では長持ちしないんだよと言ってお釈迦様は予言してあったんですね
仏教は一応隣の島で頑張って守ってくれるだろうと
そういうことで 一応スリランカ人は最近までは踏ん張ってはいたんです
今はなんか諦めてるみたいですけど
で 仏教はとにかくもうもう生き残してやるぞと
で 頑張ったところはちゃんと頑張ったんですよ
まあ西洋人にもちゃんと教えてあげて
そちらにも仏教は知られるようにして
まあそれぞれまあそれから頑張ってくださいということでね
できるだけのことはね
だから仏教はスリランカという島で守られるということはお釈迦様の予言だそうです
しかし一応お釈迦様の教えっていうのはそういうすごい素晴らしい教えで
インド人にとってはなんかまだまだ難しいみたいんですね
理解する どう考えたって難しいんです
昨日夜テレビでずっと２時までいろんなものを番組見ていたんですよ
全て宗教番組ですけど
だけどね すごいチャンネルがありまして
回せ回す回すものは何か宗教
何か宗教と あれを聞いたら
やっぱりこんなレベルか
と インドっていうのは
すごい単純でくだらない
でも音楽祭大会みたいなもんでね
一つの仙人と名前書いてますよ
それなのに もう何かおじいさんがもうマイクを持って踊りながら歌ってるんですね
ヴィシュヌやらもうアルジュンやらね
そういう神々ね 一人だけ何か分かりやすく何か喋ったんですよ
彼が言うのはこの知識よりは愛することが大事ですよと
そればっかりずっと喋って喋ってつまらないんだから
次のチャンネルはそういうふうにする
だと言っても 私はヒンディー語もベンガル語も分かってるわけじゃないんですよ
そう言うと困りますけどもね
でも言ってることはそのことなんです
分からなくても だからインドにはなかなかね
理解できそう だから日本人にはね
やっぱりすごく勉強派もあるし
またそんなに宗教背景っていうのはね
ないんだからね 邪魔が少ないんですよ
みんなこのこちらに来ている日本の坊さんたちとかね
いろいろことこと言ったっても
それは自分たちの失敗で
日本の若者っていうのはね
そう捨てたもんではないんですよ
もしちょっとしっかりした論理的なことをね
聞くと すぐもう頭がまあ開いてくれます
だからインドで見つかるお坊さんたちが何と言おうとも
日本の社会っていうのはね
そう捨てたものではありません
で ブッダの教えは理解できる土台はね
びっしりできてます ただまあもう勉強ばっかしやら仕事ばっかしとかね
言っても時間ないでしょうね
あれがもう私は言うのは時間ないじゃなくて才能がないと
才能があったらもうそんな苦労しなくたって勉強できるでしょうし
才能があったらもうすぐ仕事できるでしょうし
やっぱり才能っていうのはもう八時間の仕事はなんとかして
もう五時間で六時間で終わって
自分のために二時間ぐらいもう儲かることなんですよ
でないと生きていられないんです
だからそれだけあればね
もうみんなもっとすごく理解してくれると思います
まあ一応そういう話はそこで終了いたします
ハンデダニビッケリアマンテヤニボ ワユダンマサンカーラ アッパマーデーナ サンパ
ーデーテ ハンデダニビッケリアマンテヤニボ ワユダンマサンカーラ アッパマーデーナ サンパーデーテ ハンデダニビッケリアマ
ンテヤニボ ワユダンマサンカーラ アッパマーデーナ サンパーデーテ
アヤム タターガ タッセ タッティマーワーチャ Sādhu! Sādhu! Sādhu! まあハンデダニビッケリというのは
まあではみんな君たちに最後に告げます
まあ言っておきますというぐらいの単純な意味です
まあまあ一応憐れみを持って君たちに語ります
すべての物事は消え去る
消えていくものである
ですから 怠ることなく修行に頑張ってくださいというわけです
以上です